it was a subdued celebration at
Parliament when ranel Vikram singer was
sworn in he'll serve until 2024 the
remainder of his predecessor's term
for most people outside the building
there's no reason to celebrate Sri Lanka
has turned into a nation waiting in
queues and hundreds of people are
standing in line trying to get a
passport to leave the country
Ramesh Fernando has been queuing for two
days he says he wants to escape the dire
situation he and his family are in
my current job is very bad the
government has not increased our
salaries while prices are very high
because of the expensive fuel it is
difficult for everyone now in Sri Lanka
and because of that I have decided to
leave
is taking care of his niece they've been
stuck in the queue at the immigration
office for days the uncle explains why
they want to send her away
we can't afford to buy nutritious food
only cheap vegetables we have no money
for beetroot or carrots prices have
tripled these political changes are only
a political game not meant to solve
people's problems
hundreds of people have spent two nights
here sleeping and eating on the pavement
most of them want to find jobs in the
Middle East the inauguration
has not stopped them from leaving the
country they don't believe that anything
will change anytime soon this queue here
at the immigration office is the longest
I've seen so far in the country it shows
the sheer desperation Sri Lankans are in
the president's first promise was to
bring all parties together to form a
national government to tackle the
economic crisis victimizing this problem
is not his expertise or his experience
that he has a considerable amount and I
think he also has a reasonable amount of
international Goodwill his problem is
domestically the political credibility
the new president has warned that
protesters will be dealt with strongly
but the protesters say Vikram a singer
doesn't have a political mandate as he
lost his seat during the last
parliamentary elections
if he fails to achieve political
stability analysts say Sri Lanka will
sing deeper into crisis it's only a
matter of time before people run out of
money to buy even one meal a day step
fasten Al Jazeera Colombo